this Settler's story this video is a
little bit different than some of the
others that I've done in the past on a
few different counts you notice that
I've let my hair down and I'm dressed a
little bit more casually than I I
usually go and one of my favorite band
shirts of one of my favorite bands and
I'm going to be talking about something
that has run as a course throughout my
life really from my
you know childhood years I would say
from six or seven years old all the way
up to the present and it connects with
things that I've done video wise that
you might be aware of or you might not
uh also writings that I have out there
so I'm talking about heavy metal music
and specifically in the 1970s and the
1980s which became an integral part of
my life I won't say that I built my
entire personality around it but it was
a really central part of my identity I
viewed Myself by the 1980s as a metal
head and you know at a certain point I I
kind of left that behind in a way that
I'll tell you about in a bit but I
grabbed it back in my 30s and have
continued on with that well into my now
50s so
I should start at the beginning now I
was born the same year as heavy metal
and heavy metal didn't just begin with
Black Sabbath there were other bands
that were also centrally important Deep
Purple Uriah Heap UFO
um you know there were others that were
kind of in the background that didn't
get quite as much prominence but you
know show you that there was something
cool going on all these bands brought
out albums in 1970 Lucifer's friend in
Germany sir Lord Baltimore in the United
States and then throughout the early 70s
so many other bands joined the picture
but heavy metal wasn't quite you know a
clear genre people would talk about
heavy rock or the heaviness of things or
they would talk about Hard Rock right
and there's a lot of overlap and
interconnection and now I was born in
1970 and by the time that I was
listening to the radio along with my
friends or checking out records that
they had or getting records of my own
there were quite a few bands that would
later be identified as heavy metal that
I was getting into one of these was kiss
that was probably the biggest band for
all of us in part because they had the
makeup and you know great music to
listen to one of my friends actually had
Kiss Alive and we'd go up in his room
Jeff Van Meter me and him and Jay and
we'd listen to this and we'd read
through all the album notes so we'd go
over to my house and we'd get the
crayons out and you know I would draw
Ace Freely and and they would draw Peter
Chris or Gene Simmons or Paul Stanley
and we'd all talk about who our favorite
member of Kiss was I actually actually I
even had a kiss lunch box at one time
but there were other bands that you
could hear
out there on the radio that were making
an impact as well or sometimes you'd
have a friend whose older brother or
sister got into that so in elementary
school I was already hearing a good bit
of heavy metal there was AC DC on the
airwaves with TNT that just fascinated
us right some people say AC DC isn't
heavy metal but they certainly were part
of that spectrum and we would hear other
stuff as well I mean Led Zeppelin has
some pretty heavy songs that made it
onto the radio the scorpions in the 70s
as well and we could go on and on
and so I was hearing this stuff and
responding to it Without Really knowing
what to call it and there were other
bands that were you know similarly doing
hard or heavy stuff that we don't
actually consider to be metal and it was
all kind of mixed together and
in the 1980s for me that started to
coalesce in a way that helped me figure
out what I was actually interested in
listening to and you know so by the time
that I was in Middle School
there were you know Van Halen we would
hear them and and you know 1984 had come
out
um and there's going to be a story about
that but there was also Def Leppard I
had the Pyromania tape you know so I'm
I'm hearing this stuff on the radio
getting my hands on on you know tapes uh
that I play in my boom box or on my
little cassette recorder listening to
the radio hearing cool stuff out there
and my friends would also be doing this
and so Van Halen's 1984 was a really
important album for me in part because
it would lead me to my what was to
become my absolute favorite band really
from 1984 well into my early 20s
that's Iron Maiden now you might say
well how the hell did Van Halen lead you
to Iron Maiden so this friend of mine in
eighth grade Walter Clothier he was a
Metalhead and I didn't know that at the
time and he told me that he would make a
recording of 1984 because he had the
album at home and I was like cool so I
gave him a 45 minute cassette tape that
was what we would use back then because
usually albums would be shorter than 45
minutes if they were longer you could
put something on the other side but
usually it would be a bit shorter
and there was enough room that he was
like well let's add something else in
there so what did he put
a song that perhaps
is
um you know among dozens of amazing
songs that they have put out perhaps
their best
iron maidens the trooper
and so I'm listening to 1984 which is a
great album by the way you know
sometimes people are like oh it's not as
good as the previous Van Halen albums
it's different but it's it's good and
some of the songs on there like House of
Pain they were doing years and years
before it ever got recorded on 1984. but
iron maidens the trooper
was like taking it up to not a higher
level like three levels up from Van
Halen's 1984. I heard it
and something in me the very first few
bars began responding to it I remember
exactly where I was I was listening to
it in a park sitting on a bench in
Waukesha playing it on my Boombox and I
heard this and I was like what is this
so I went to Walter afterwards you know
he gave it to me on a Friday I saw him
the next Monday and I was like what is
this song that you put at the end of the
Van Halen stuff and he said oh that's
Iron Maiden you like them I mean I can
get you some more of their stuff if you
want to and I was like yeah and I I gave
him the tape back and he put iron
maiden's uh peace of mind on the other
side this is before I bought the album
which I I did shortly as as well and I
listened to this and I was like holy
crap this is what I've been looking for
my entire life without even knowing it
right
so this you know Walter was also helpful
he's like this is heavy metal man you
know and and people were talking about
it at the time it was becoming a major
Force Within the Music Industry and so
that was the end of my eighth grade
moving into freshman year of high school
over that summer
you know I not only got my hands on iron
maiden's uh peace of mind and Number of
the Beast I also like started hearing
other things on the radio I heard rats
round and round I remember exactly where
I was when that was playing we are
getting off the uh Expressway I-94 I
think into Brookfield on an off ramp
with all those you know lights you know
those street lights that that Shone
orange at the time and this came on and
I was like holy crap what is this you
know so there was all these cool things
I got my hands on rat I got Motley
Crue's Shout at the Devil I started
buying circus and hit parater so I could
learn more about this music I started
listening even more to the radio
particularly to wqfm which wasn't a
metal station as such but a hard rock
station but they were playing more and
more metal and so joining the Columbia
record Club I got you know rat Motley
Crew I got Twisted Sister I got
um black sabbaths born again I got Judas
Priest defender of the faith those are
so I got crocuses uh the blitz what else
did I get Sammy Hagar what VOA I think
it was and there were a number of other
albums and I'm not I can't quite
remember all of the ones that I I got at
that time but there there were quite a
few
and including a misstep Molly Hatchet
I forget which one it was it's the one
with the guy on the horse with the ax
Molly Hatchet turned out to be southern
rock rather than heavy metal but they
look pretty metal you know
so that's all happening in the summer
and I'm also like you know buying tapes
learning about these finding out about
uh bands that uh I didn't know about or
I I knew about but I didn't know that
they were part of this you know I go on
camping trips with uh these other kids
and parents Without Partners that I've
talked about in other videos and they're
playing masters of metal as we're going
around and drinking uh stolen Brandy and
slogan that my friend Jerry had taken
from his dad's stuff and you know we're
hearing Y and T and hearing rainbow and
Dio and uh more new kiss and
um Iron Maiden and all these other cool
bands on this compilation that we played
over and over and over again
so I come to school and you know I've
started to grow out my hair I'm starting
to dress a little bit more metal you
know eventually at Christmas time I'll
get like a studded bracelet that I'll
wear I'm craving leather craving denim
you know and I find other people who are
as equally into this as me and they
start turning me on to more and more
bands this friend of mine Chris whitham
who actually turned out to be kind of a
bad guy there's a whole story I could
tell about him
he was so important because he would
lend me tapes he'd be like oh man you
got to hear these guys you like Motley
Crue and rant how about some wasp check
this stuff out oh you like that here's
some Motorhead check these guys out
here's Raven they're they're a band that
not a lot of people know about here's
some sacks and here and he was just like
constantly generously either taping
stuff for me or just giving me a tape
and saying go ahead and dub it and bring
it back to me and um you know there was
that going on I also started going to
record stores I bought deals Holy Diver
that uh like in the first week of school
in Waukesha my mom wasn't thrilled with
me bringing that home but I was like
developing this this taste for metal and
then there were other people who were
like oh man you got to hear this new
band Metallica they are really something
and then learning about Metallica meant
learning about Mega Death so I'm hearing
early thrash there's accept there's all
these different bands that are now
becoming part of a cosmos and you know
on my spring break in Florida I bought
two tapes at Walmart in the bargain rack
I got Judas priests sin after sin and
black sabbaths we sold our souls for
rock and roll and I was you know kind of
puzzled because I was like man Judas
Priest sounds very different in this
than they do in Defenders of the faith
because their sound had evolved over
those so
1983 19 what
77 maybe 78 you know things had changed
over over that period
and I was getting more and more and more
into it and having friends who were
equally into it and you know doing the
silly things like writing these band
logos on my notebooks on my jeans and
you know geeking out with other people
about this music that I'm responding to
and I got in with a bunch of uh other
kids mostly older kids you know and we'd
go to concerts and thrash out you know
do the head banging and all that sort of
stuff had a great time with that and
that continued on well into my you know
the end of my teens and my 20s I
listened to heavy metal a lot when I was
in the Army uh after I got out I started
to Branch out into other music but there
were new bands on the scene like or new
to me rather like Queen's Reich you know
I I heard operation mind crime and I was
like holy crap this is amazing then I
started listening to their older catalog
you know and then by the time I was in
college they came out with Empire
meanwhile all these other bands like
Judas Priest and Iron Maiden and you
know Metallica were bringing out new
stuff constantly no not constantly but
in kind of a sequence same thing with
Motorhead same thing with Dio you know
and I was I was you know the Scorpions
too I was finding all of this music that
I responded to and my musical taste did
widen and change a bit in part through
the influence of a friend of mine Marco
who gave me tapes full of all sorts of
other things including a lot of punk and
Post Punk and alternative you know the
Violent Femmes were here in in Milwaukee
they were a massive influence you
couldn't you know not listen to the
Violent Femmes and they weren't metal
but they were cool too
and you know then in in the middle of my
college
um time grunge suddenly became big here
in the Midwest I know it was bigger out
there in Seattle and stuff but we're
always a little bit behind and grunge
kind of took the wind out of the sails
on some of the metal stuff that was
going on and I think it you know in some
ways it occupied a similar Sonic space
you have you know heaviness to it think
about you know Stone Temple Pilots or
Nirvana or um even you know there were
metal bands Alice in Chains is both
grunge and metal and you did have some
other metal bands that were doing cool
things like prong with weird time
signatures I had by the way at that time
gotten into playing bass I learned to
play bass in the Army and after I got
out with my first paycheck
I bought myself a cheap Aria Pro 2 base
Betsy blue uh is is her name and a
practice amp and then eventually I'd buy
myself a 200 watt power amp with a 15
inch speaker so I could you know play
some some cool stuff and I did play in a
few bands and I'd cover a lot of metal
stuff you know I learned a lot of Black
Sabbath songs a lot of Metallica songs a
lot of Iron Maiden songs a lot of Judas
Priest songs quite a few things and
people would want me to play with them
right but I you know I had it I also
played a lot of Pearl Jam and Nirvana
and things like that when I was in in
college too and so you know I was
listening to a wider range of things
and I I wouldn't say that I ever stopped
listening to metal entirely but it had
become at least the 1980s and 1970s
stuff it had become secondary to other
things that I was listening to by the
time that I was in graduate school
School in the mid to late 90s in the
early 2000s
and then I with my family we moved into
a house on my family's land that I
purchased with my inheritance after my
mother had died
and um
I was watching a cable show on VH VH1
and it was this four-part series about
heavy metal so this would be like maybe
2003 or so
and I'm you know I always found these
kind of biopics interesting and they're
playing the music
and I'm listening to this and I was like
man that stuff was really good why did I
ever like
stop listening to it or not listen to it
quite so much what what was going on and
I was like I need to start listening to
this stuff again and I actually had
quite a few CDs of of you know metal
bands that I had held on to and I you
know I I put them on my computer and
then I talked to my cousin who had a
huge collection himself and my sister
came into town one time and she had a
whole bunch of stuff and I put all that
on my computer and then I would go to
use CD stores and just as I you know
frequented used record stores buying
stuff in the 80s used CD stores in the
90s and 2000s were kind of a place to go
and I started buying more and more stuff
and I bought things that I'd never had
before and putting them into
compilations that I would listen to as I
was driving
and it was around that time that I got
my oldest kid at that time my only kid
cat into not just heavy metal
but specifically kiss the hottest band
in the world she knew by the time that
she was like two or three I could say
who's the hottest band in the world
should say kiss and she would ask me to
play the songs for her she also loved
you know uh songs like Godzilla by Blue
Oyster Cult she really got into UFO
interestingly and and you know loves
them to this day which is kind of a cool
thing because lots of people are into
you know wearing the shirts for Iron
Maiden or Metallica or kiss not that
many people know about UFO and say are
they going to play you know uh
lights out or a doctor doctor at this
this thing you know Michael schechner
group came to town and I got to see them
with my wife and I recorded some of the
stuff and sent them off to cat because
cat loves those those songs so much so
anyway that continued on and I was
really really fortunate in that my
second wife my real wife let's call her
because I had my first marriage annulled
um
loves heavy metal as much as I do and so
we've gone to
must be dozens and dozens of concerts
together
over the 12 years that we've been
married we've seen so many bands I've
also seen some with cat too you know
this last year at Summerfest we got to
see Queens right together and
um we saw autograph the end of their
their act and it was pretty good they're
they're not so much a metal band but
they're known for Turn up the radio and
we saw Vixen a band that in the 1980s it
was an all woman band and they weren't
that great but the people that they have
in the band now are amazing you know so
it's it's a great time and I get to
share it with people that I I care about
I've also got friends who are super into
it
um Scott to ruli for example with whom I
do the classic metal class which we're
going to start up again in November
we've both been rather busy but we
managed to get over 20 different
sessions in on that in the past I write
heavy metal philosopher I've got other
friends who I've made over the years who
are equally into metal and you know
specifically the stuff from the 70s and
80s and those bands continuing on
through the 90s and 2000s and I found
some newer bands who I really love as
well typically sounding kind of like the
older stuff like Orchid wonderful band
sounds a lot like they make the songs
Black Sabbath never got around to making
many others that I could I could bring
up as well so this is something that is
really valuable to me I don't think
any day goes by without me listening to
some music at least I play some of it
myself as well
on my
handy dandy banjo I mean you might say
that doesn't that's not very metal but
you know I can do scorpions and Black
Sabbath and Iron Maiden and Judas Priest
and Motorhead and other bands on the
banjo
sounding good enough except as well as
another uh big one for me
so I thought I would share this with you
there isn't really any Grand closure to
this because I imagine all probably
along with my wife be going to concerts
listening to this sort of stuff when
when the bands die off and stop playing
we'll go to Tribute bands and we'll
continue listening to it and loving it
throughout the rest of my existence and
I I you know I'll close with this
um I've been putting together a list of
the songs that I would most like to have
played at my memorial service after I
die you know
I'll give you a few of them
um will burn the Sky by The Scorpions
Zero the Hero by Black Sabbath maybe the
trooper we'll we'll see I'm going to put
together an entire list and then you
know we'll see if my wife outlives me
and plays them or perhaps it'll be my uh
oldest child cat doing it uh since they
like heavy metal so much but that is uh
the the whole story
um I don't know if you're into that kind
of music but if you are you you kind of
know what I'm talking about here and if
you're not
maybe you want to see whether you would
enjoy listening to some of these great
bands from the 1970s and 1980s that made
such a huge stamp with their wonderful
music the heaviness the hardness the
lyrics the uh Beauty the brutality all
of these things combined